yo yo yo yo hey-ho hey-ho hey-ho puzzly
this dance is a rock enough for you
this displays it for the Kurds you
forgot never Boyd come on slow slow slow
not without cutting off my balls it was
all worth it in the end
except for my end that's cut in half
okay gonna do a just exploded houki hi
bike how you doing
if I fly I'm pretty sure nothing bad can
I thought I was still alive there little
fly little fly more little fly
damnit son of a biscuit I didn't do that
I did not do that either that is weird
[Music]
thank you for the explosion this is
called a very long spike fall
I wonder what's well [__] how long is it
not that long whoa it goes back oh you
tried to be Trixie is that the raining
blood of my son
I just can't stop pleasuring myself oh
it's a burden oh woe is me
do I like that me do me like that oh I'm
a pirate oh I'm a sexy little pirate who
are do me like that oh yes me do don't
look at me this is what happens when I'm
home alone with no one question why I do
things why did I win after I said all
that weird stuff fly three percent
possible level well okay thanks Oh
Giants would throw I see okay let me
just try this again
take a deep relaxing breath get back
here you ball bastard I just spit all
over my screen cuz you're an [__]
alright I just have a habit of going off
at the worst times okay okay then thanks
still happening still doing things my
anus is exploding blood huh I'll be the
judge of that
okay so far so good
always another chance for me to go oh
this is much different than I thought
that's one top 99 to smart
[Music]
son-of-a-bitches you miss it may look
like you hit me but in reality you
missed Oh God
somehow my body got on backwards but I'm
okay now kind of a little bit maybe just
go swing I only got my son hahaha
good job decoying for me it was totally
worth it in the end this guy is called
funny its death wins murders all my
kitties die it will be funny for me
so this is how you're gonna be a tricky
bastard Oh still alive and somehow I'm
gonna bring this home I'm gonna do it
okay if I can't even beat my own thing
[Applause]
[Music]
wouldn't be one at all cheetah we all
throw finally someone spelled it
correctly I got one more ball no no no
[Music]
it's kind of hard to throw cuz I'm not
all the way in there hope you thought
you could get me no you going the kid oh
[Music]
don't kill me tiny box em please what
are you doing are you caressing me find
a box Tim is not to be trusted
and we should not let him do anything
our swar throw that was horrific let's
get started
hop welp killed the other baby I'm just
the worst kind of human being
oh whoa hey there whoa whoa whoa I see
it okay stop putting the store if I
could just hit
because this kid okay you can stop being
dragged behind you're leaving your
brother to take all the brunt of the
mines not really standing up job they
can breathe a little lazier huh where am
I going
did I pass the skill test because ready
to die
markiplier run is a deadly run this is
very impossible
you only got my balls and they're made
of titanium and or steel this day what a
do sure you are no paint no mines gonna
get me down what you launched me into
the winner's circle
technically I beat this get out of your
sassy suit
okay thanks for the distraction
my still alive oh this one is very
difficult and by very difficult I mean
okay somehow still alive okay dad oh hey
whoa what's gonna know oh oh oh that's
so weird
nope here take my son thanks for
watching if you want to see more happy
wheels right now check the description
or click the annotation for the full
happy wheels playlist and if you want to
see more happy wheels in the future
please click the like button to let me
know thanks again everyone and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye